il gioco ma saper preparare buon come to
this new video secondo episodio di
diritto fabio ragazzi spero che vi
piaccia e quindi buona visione let's go
successo dove sono finito taivè
peggio è giusto 14 mar fixed of it dove
perché non ho nono chiavi non m'hanno
dato chiavi cosa devo fare qua poi
ancora barricato no a posto io volevo
entrare qua a trovare una chiave andare
a fare in culo ma non sono riuscito
perché si è barricato sudista qualche
parte andrò non lo so ma mi sa per testa
porta oh che bello scopriamo le altre
istanze visto che finora è stato tutto
troppo tranquillo piena utopia hashino
qua certo non vedo perché il
protagonista dovrebbe uscire mi sembra
tutto molto allegro e divertente i conti
ma lei poi meglio che entro in una
stanza le stanze sono piccole trovi una
chiave che i vecchi il jam schiere vai
ad aprire un'altra porta c'è tutto così
sto gioco
anzi non la trovi perché in questo caso
non l'ho trovata neanche ho visto
abbastanza bisogna riuscire a sopportare
adesso sì sì usciamo andiamo all'uscita
ci riusciremo senza problemi figurati se
succede qualcosa tipo che si spostano i
banchi o tipo che i marchi tentano di
accerchiarsi la vita non si chiuderà
amica sta porta non comparirà mica
nessuno in 3 2 1
ma sul serio michiara cava la sono
scampata meno male pensavo
sono dieci anni che parlo che dico
cazzate e in dieci anni non ho capito un
cazzo va bene va bene
posso sempre andare all'uscita visto che
non manca gatal andato sarà andato di là
ciao arrivederci
[Applauso]
mi spiega che a che cosa si rannicchia
sto giocando
ok serve non hai il freno e lo sai cosa
devo fare qualche ciapet questo e crede
manor già visto il suo gioco giocato due
volte cosa fai zio spinge il muro mi
sembra roba veramente utile da fare
allenamento quale in palestra usciamo
o la portata per di sopra grazie a quel
tizio e più efficiente di un ascensore
la stanza meeting è chiusa o salve
non è che vi può portare anche di sotto
già che c'è io mi farei ma l'attrice
ogni tanto prova perché emanando un mio
amico a nando se hai voglia pino spin
off lo chiamava scherzavo ti chiami
pinos noto il nome
mi chiedo allo stato di prima col
capezzolo nell'aria
barca buttana the two sorella morta ce
l'ha a sono quelli prima ragazzi e li
difendete da pinos che non è il massimo
sta e oneri cosa qua
essere andato ma perche sono ancora qua
dentro qualcuno me lo dice una chiave
successo sta chiave c'è più c'è più
batteri sopra che chernobyl prova bene
era 45 o per sé uscita ho trovato cosa
che ha trovato tra l'altro una chiave
cosa
finché non c'è pino tutto a posto ho
trovato una chiave ma non ho capito cosa
aprendo una porta qua dietro c'è una
porta ma poi
trans
ho bisogno di qualcosa per tagliare la
catena ce l'avevo prima ero andato nelle
cantine per riuscire a prendere qualcosa
non l'hai preso sei un rintronato è
meglio devo tornare giù dai cosa sto
vedendo
all venuto sarà pure il muro fornuto ci
manca solo questo cioè mancari ha
comunque
ma bello mi volevo tornare in cantina
tollo st voglia di tornare 4 posto del
merda non dicono anche dove era qua qua
devi prenderlo sei anni fa
tranquilli tutto a posto non guardate
questi dopo le cuffie almeno voi
salvatevi ighalo
esco mai brodo
finalmente lo zio lo zio di non è pinos
lui e l'altro giovanni giovanni dica che
devo fare devo fare qua a giova anzi de
marseille e
capitana che è successo
giovanni organi
ma palazzina giovanni era giovanna
giovanna giorno giovanna
in appello
devi stare calma che stai calma calma
stanno anche le campane attenzione
attenzione che qua
giovanna ciò
che succede o
nicchia no bellissimo 2009 un'ora prima
dell'incidente amica abbiamo anche una
trama in questo gioco e cazzo sto
vedendo io sono alto m e basta un metro
e 80 voglia di crescere sono sono
veramente bassissimo arriva il culo
della gente ma un'ora prima degli
incidenti in che senso
e così è successo quasi ma siete un po
indecisi sulla dovete andare
effettivamente ragazzi però mi reco al
piano di sotto che almeno qua posso
uscire con aspetto ci stava
non so cosa succede succede
quello sta chiamando qualcuno ma cosa è
successo qua io ragazzi non so poi non
scapperei poi fate il caso che vi pare
non posso uscire neanche nel nel
flashback va bene e quindi
non trovare qualcosa che cambia tutto
per la musica è quindi ragazzi non
benissimo madonna che fosse
effettivamente cioè non sa qui
e ci
cammini mar
[Musica]
ok deve
giovanna che ti fanno
se non lo sai parma e non lo fa style a
giocar surgeons
comunque mille verità al cazzo aria
leggi e se non sta camera ma veramente
ma come ha fatto a scansarsi però cosa è
successo un ora prima dell'incidente tra
l'altro è successo a vinovo
è dove lo zero voglio andare a casa non
perché voglio andare a casa questo l'ha
scritto staff della sail un del manico
lei certo di sicuro non era un po ho
trovato in piedi porco a pesca struck
una sciocchezza non c'è neanche non c'è
neanche il menù per poter mettere in
pausa non certo non c'è più schiacciato
est e non c'è celi non posso neanche
mettere in pausa perché il gioco
continua così modo nelle opzioni non ci
sono le opzioni che gioco è toccato
quota 1 non me ne frega niente di quelli
là in manicomio che scrivono le proprie
tutto ok tutto ok tutto che ha posto a
posto apposta a walkinshaw zahi hawass
niente di niente ma ne vale successo la
nostra capello c'è satana
webinar non l'ho vista porca [ __ ]
scoria labor d'asti nicchia
o anche aperta lo grazia
il 26 dicembre 1900 gli impiegati nello
staff del curling casa e non sono
preparati per i loro bella festa di
natale quando qualcuno è arrivato una
donna che ha urlato a noro state per
morire tutti
lei ha sparato a tutti quanti senza di
fare nessuno lo staff in panic ato si è
nascosto molti non ce l'hanno fatta la
polizia intorno a te investigare ha
trovato una donna nome angelica che era
stata responsabile dello sparatore
infatti era anche responsabile di un
altro di l'altro di altra sparatoria
secondo le investigazioni poliziesche
lei si era nascosta la prima sparatoria
per andare al manicomio che aveva più
disturbi di personalità e aveva nascosto
un un'arma in casa sua e la polizia ha
trovato l'arma nella scatola che era
chiusa
angelica è stata catturata dalla polizia
è stata vista corre nell'entrata del del
manicomio tenendo una torcia
ok comunque spero che lui sia piaciuto
ragazzi questo era netto fobia una
storia una lacrima strappa storia è una
storia strappa come siete ragazzi si
vede pure su questo è un mi piace anche
vari social che come aiuto dalla
descrizione se questi si schieri e noi
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
bella ragazza
[Musica]